saving money is ridiculous you guys
shouldn't save your money you should
take your money the game I've been
playing since I was 31 years old and
nobody knew I was doing it I was calling
on you guys getting money from you and
you were funding all my real estate and
that's why I was hustling so hard I was
doing 300 days a year I'd get five grand
from you four grand nine grand three
grand two grand on any given day the
price could have been anything anybody
buy a g-pod from me so I took all my
videos put it on the Nano and called it
a g-pod this in 2010 man half of you
guys were out of business okay I said
you got to get the g-pod the new g-pod
man all my videos are on the g-pop some
of you guys would buy it I'd take the
nine grand and I'd invest the entire
nine thousand in real estate all of it
didn't have fancy cars or Gucci or
nothing it wasn't traveling anytime I
travel I'd come travel to you I'd go up
to Winnipeg in Thanksgiving because we
didn't have Thanksgiving in Winnipeg the
Canadians don't do that there so I'd go
there pick up a bag come back buy some
American Real Estate and just buried in
a real estate and stay broke all the
time need motivation watch the top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggled to keep my business going I
had no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories for motivation
today so today let's learn from one of
the best grandchild Cardone and my take
on his top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two is study people I want
to know
can I Shadow work someone like you if I
would need a pitch you join The
Mastermind why haven't you done that
honestly yeah honestly yeah why haven't
you it's not me you down so what is it
[Music]
um you guys understand that any of you
that have not signed up for that it's
not me you doubt
like you can you can you can try to make
it about me but it's not me it's you
okay you guys doubt you you guys doubt
yourselves you understand you were so
far ahead of where I was when I was 21
years old I was 21 years old I was
getting pistol whipped
I was eating tranquilizers amphetamines
and had my face on a mirror all day long
like I was a wreck I was a disgrace to
my family and to myself
okay she's 21.
but you got you guys can learn the hard
way you can learn the fast way so I can
learn by Theory I need to actually feel
when I'm looking at you in this event
yeah I see promoting come to work for me
you want to come work if you don't want
to join The Mastermind guys come to work
for me
come work for me every day you want to
Shadow me come work in my office get a
salary you get paid something move
across the country like how else you
want to do it I can't
no I won't okay I mean like like I got a
life and I got business right so like
sure we got we got to figure out what
that is the way to do it the way to do
it is to study people okay if you guys
want to learn the game you've got to
study someone
and you got to go deep on one person you
can't just like look at everything that
comes your way you got to study just
like you have interior design rule
number three is know your cost of living
number three rule know exactly what your
cost of living is it is shocking to me
how many people absolutely have no idea
how much income they make how much their
taxes are how much their house payment
their car payment their electric their
water their utilities what they're
spending on their kids eating out
Chipotles ubering like you don't know if
you don't know you can't control what
you're doing okay so the first thing you
do is got to know exactly where every
single penny is going what are your kids
getting what is your wife spending what
are you spending what does gas cost you
oil costs you tires cost you count it
all if you simply take the last 90 days
and look through your checkbook and your
credit cards and you just total all that
up that is your cost of living okay take
that divide by three and that's what
it's costing you February month you need
to know that down to a nickel know
exactly what your cost of living is so
that you can start one controlling that
and number two outgrow that rule number
four is seek cash flow what Roi are you
looking when you're investing okay Roi
return on investment okay or we would
call Cash Flow It's the cash flow that
I'm really looking for okay there's
there's a couple terms one is uh you
could use Roi cash flows the term all
these are made up though guys like it's
like how good's the building the better
the building is the better the future
the building is the less I need for
return Why number one reason you want to
write this down the number one reason
and you need to know these you need to
know this is why I'm doing this
he's not sure why he's doing it because
right now he's like what's my Roi okay
number one reason it might be because of
your age but number one reason is what
preserve capital
why am I buying the real estate okay why
am I buying the real estate I want to
preserve Capital Melissa gave me a
million dollars I'm a consultant I
consult their business she gives me a
million dollars to consult the business
I want to preserve the million dollars
if you keep the million dollars you're
going to lose it you're going to get
taxed out of it it's going to depreciate
everybody agree you want to convert
paper to buildings
okay I like I have a rule I never
convert paper to more paper
I'll I'd convert it to bitcoin before I
converted back to dollars or treasury
bills personally
I actually believe in the blockchain
more than I believe in the treasury
Department
oh yeah this guy oh here go the Maxis
[Music]
Bitcoin people go crazy now watch okay
how many crypto people in the room
these people are nuts
okay they're like the drug addicts of
the blockchain
okay you start talking to these people
you drop a quarter in them tell me about
crypto oh
these people are taught for 17 days
all right so one you want to protect
your capital okay this is why people get
it now I want to keep it the way to keep
it is to convert it you cannot keep cash
without losing it it's going down in
value
in your lifetime it's lost 70 of its
value my lifetime has lost 70 percent of
my value yeah exactly okay one you want
to protect your Capital number one two
you want cash flow these are my criteria
for investing in anything that's why I
don't load up on bitcoin because it
doesn't hit number two it doesn't cash
flow also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is find the right
people all you have to do is go out and
be willing to go talk to people and if
you go talk to enough of the right
people then you will find the right
person and and literally that this was
so funny because he uh was telling me
after he got back he's like literally
within the first uh 48 hours I had met
the two people that were going to make
everything that happened on that show
possible I knew I knew it wasn't it
wasn't a week it wasn't it wasn't a
month it was literally The First 48
hours all I did for the first 10 days is
meet people
okay but you got to meet the right
people okay who are the right people
you know who are assets and who are
liabilities okay on day one in 19 days
in this workbook we're going to take a
list of the people that you know okay
and the people you don't know that could
actually change the the the the future
of your life okay
who could actually change the future
make you the millionaire the DECA
millionaire
because I promise you you ain't getting
there
without them
and the people that you know
have you where you are
just so you know like the people that
you know if your network is your net
worth
then the network you have right now has
something to do with the network that
you have right now number six is be a
threat you guys got to become a threat
to your environment you got to become a
threat to your environment you got to
become such a threat to your environment
people start like your competition
starts talking about you because that's
free promotion
yeah
you got to get people to promote you and
you can't nobody's going to promote
somebody not winning
you know they're not going to hate on
people losing they're going to hate on
people that are winning
it just comes with the thing so in in
that promotion because people don't
remember you remember a Tylenol Tylenol
was taking off the shelves 20 years ago
number one best-selling headache
medication in the world today
and it was taking off the shelves
so so you have to figure out how to get
how to do something big enough in your
Marketplace you know the fourth reason
to Market is to get a customer but if
you hit the third one you're going to
get the fourth one
so I don't know if I answered your
question but you can't stay you can't
you can't just keep being a 50 car store
right so the 10x concept would be this
like okay we did 50. we're going to
figure out how to do 500. right you
don't go 50 to 55 because you're never
going to get to 55. rule number seven is
get financial education cash is not King
there is a king
and it is not cash cash is garbage okay
cash flow now would be a different
conversation
constant cash flow can't LoCash is going
down in value in fact I want to give you
something I did a little study this
morning in in 1960
okay this is a conversation everybody
here if you want to know more about
money you have to figure this out okay
in 1960 if I had one thousand dollars
and then I come out to if I come out to
2018.
how much money how many thousands of
dollars do you think I would need in
1960 to buy the same services today
as in 1960. I was born in 1958 by the
way
8 000 in 1992 and 1992 this thousand
dollars and you take it out to to 2018
you would need you would need uh
[Music]
Seventeen hundred and forty four dollars
to buy the same goods and services okay
this was 82.69 so now this is really
really important don't get lost here
you're like what just happened here okay
I'm going to show you I'm going to give
you a very simple very very simple and
I'm going to explain to you what Warren
Buffett says only a handful of people on
planet Earth understand it's called
inflation there's a thousand dollars
and I'm just going to pull off what
looks like eight
yeah that's eight
I gotta add one it's short 100 okay I
wonder how close I am maybe somebody can
count this out okay okay now in 1960
when I was when I was two years old this
is what it took you could go with a
thousand dollars and you'd buy whatever
washing machine dryer car payments house
payments blah blah blah if you wanted to
buy those items today those same items
today this is the understanding of
inflation you would need eight times the
money to purchase the same products okay
so what happened okay ask yourself this
question a thousand dollars in 1960 is
worth what today
if I had a thousand dollars put it in my
drawer in 1960 came back 57 years later
58 years later and grabbed it how much
money would be in the drawer same
thousand dollars is in there nothing
happened to the thousand dollars you
understand we still have a thousand
dollars this is this is inflation
simplified
this is what they don't teach at school
right a thousand dollars in two in 1950
and eight is a 1960 it is a thousand
dollars in
2018. the difference is the difference
however is this bought this bought this
product right here
okay and by 2018
it didn't buy the same product it bought
one eighth
one eighth of the products
okay now what does that mean to you that
means cash
[Music]
right because what happened to these
products these products went up in price
these products went up eight times
while money went down or the pr that
went up and this stayed the same however
you want to figure it out but cash is
not King folks okay cash is not King in
fact you'd have probably been better off
buying a thousand dollars worth of real
estate back in 1960. and getting rid of
your dough
because what do you think that piece of
property would be worth today if it was
in a decent location well number eight
is never lend money never loan money to
anyone ever listen to me you're not a
bank you're not an ATM you're not a
credit card okay you got a name it ain't
MasterCard it is I need to make money I
need to take care of family I need to
take care of my business I need to get
my wealth right I need to create wealth
and then and not even then would you
ever loan money to anyone especially
friends and family okay do not do it I'm
telling you don't solve their money
problem all they're going to do is suck
you into their money problem so number
four I have never done this I've done
this one time in in literally 30 years
okay and that time I was disappointed
never loan money to anyone if they can't
get it from a bank they shouldn't be
able to get it from you their money
problems will become your money problems
let them go fix those if they can and
then come back and I know what you're
going to tell me you're gonna be like oh
Grand man it's all about the money with
you that's why it's called the
non-negotiable money tips this is about
money okay I'm staying away from people
that got money problems if I'm a real
friend of yours and I'm going through
trouble right now why would I want to
bring my trouble to you stay away from
people that have money problems okay
these are my non-negotiable money tips
look I came up from nothing if you don't
know who I am literally started with
nothing 25 years old I had no money no
credit no Finance no Mentor there was no
training or education about money I knew
nothing about it I just knew one thing I
wanted it and I also knew that I wanted
more than I had and so I started
studying and reading every book I could
on finance all these wealthy people I
ran into this book The Millionaire Next
Door I'm Gonna Save my way to money I'm
gonna I'm gonna not drink the coffee and
I'm gonna I'm gonna buy the used truck
okay it's ridiculous okay you guys could
get a million dollars you know less
about money than people that are broke
okay a million dollars is not enough
money for you it's not enough money for
your future it's not enough money for
your security and it's definitely not
enough money for retirement rule number
nine is get rich in assets I highly
advise this stay broke thing
good man because what I did was I got
rich in assets
and broken cash and after what you guys
saw happen Friday
three Banks this weekend another one
this morning this ain't going to be over
okay but what happened was we were I
think most of us in the room were taught
hey work hard how many were taught that
yeah bust your ass save your money yeah
the first two parts are right the third
one's wrong you don't want to save your
money you want to get rid of money
convert money
to something else
either another dealership car
dealerships are about real estate
they're not about cars
right you're right or wrong amen that's
it man the the the the the cars
basically support the owner in owning
the real estate that one day in the
future will be worth a lot of money and
number 10 the last time before some very
special bonus Clips is Live Your Dreams
hey all you guys out there living the
dream
I always hear people say that hey how
you doing man I'm living the dream
that's what people say I'm like really
I don't think so I've never said that I
hate that saying by the way I'm living
the dream but are you really and so
that's what I want to ask you are you
living your dream and what does it mean
do you even know if you've written it
down what do you want to visit who do
you want to hang with
what do you want to do with your time
you know you have kids you have a
marriage
what's life look like
you know for me I really didn't know
what it looked like I just wanted you to
be better have some a little more I was
telling my sister the other day she's
like do you ever imagine your life would
be this I said no and that's a regret I
have
I regret
that I actually didn't imagine and
didn't have
or know what was possible
and I think it's a shame so many of us
don't know what's possible because we
never get to experience
like right now I'm in Cabo San Lucas
I'm at the Villa Cortez at Palmilla the
one and only Amia
hotel and they have this house here it's
a five bedroom five or six bedroom house
and we come here a couple times a year
this is our second time to be here
and it's just fantastic big infinity
pool jacuzzi over here seating areas for
probably you could entertain 25 people
out here which we've done both times
we've come we've had people guest out
here business meetings
just didn't know when I was growing up
what was possible because I grew up in a
in a
you know uh
single mom struggling trying to figure
out how to make it how we could just pay
the bills so there was nobody to like
create imagination about possibility and
and I hope hopefully this channel if you
find this inspirational just walking
around looking at this place because you
guys can have this anybody can have this
I'm telling you you can dream big enough
align yourself with the right people
never quit on the dream
I'm telling you believe it or not and
maybe if you're beat up right now in
life you don't believe anything's
possible but I promise if you don't quit
surround yourself with the right people
and can actually see the dream see
what's possible then you can actually
start planning on what you need to do
who you need to meet what you need to
know
why do I insist that apartments are the
greatest investment of the group why
should you focus here for your initial
foray into real estate investing in
short it's because Apartments passed a
number of tests that are vital to you
not having to worry about whether or not
you're going to make money in a deal
okay you're here to win you're here to
make money I'm all in an apartments for
key reasons first apartments or real
assets when you own apartments and you
own real tangible assets you benefit
from a number of things one you benefit
from appreciation going forward if you
picked a good location cash flow right
now want you sit and wait and it's more
expensive in the future going forward to
build these apartments than it was to
buy them number two apartments produce
positive cash flow at least they should
if you bought it right if you got the
right debt on it and if you pick the
right property Apartments produce
positive cash flow which is the Holy
Grail of finance a concept that very few
people ever get right almost as
importantly as inflation same thing with
cash flow you're underestimating the
value of positive cash flow when you
pick a property it is cash flow that
gives it value going forward because one
you get to keep it long term and two it
gives you security when you go to sleep
at night now that brings me to number
three this is called the multiplier
effect when rents rise if they do in
your Market apartment values increase if
you're ready to take the next step and
start investing in real estate like a
total Pro you have to start with the big
why why a particular class of asset a
lot of people watch our videos they
aspire to assets properties Yachts like
this and they should what would be some
of the advice that you would give them
what I would recommend to people is like
number one lock in that success is
important and finances are vital like
you need money and you need a lot of
money number one you need whatever you
think about money you're wrong
and and I'm telling you you're wrong
because you ain't never had any money
or been around anybody with any money so
you can't you shouldn't be making any
decisions about money it's crazy to me
how many people make decisions about
money and never had any and never had
anybody around them that had any money
so most of the people that say money
won't make you happy and it won't do
this and it won't do that I'm like you
don't know anything about money you
should you should just have a clean
slate and say I don't know anything
about money so money's important number
two uh don't lose money you need to
invest in that's guaranteed to make
you money once you earn it man take it
and use it for something that will make
you more money don't keep it don't save
it don't Ira it don't 401K it don't go
buy Gucci and crime shoes don't do any
of that in the beginning okay
yeah no no it's a terrible
you need it you need you need in the
beginning right you need money you need
you don't want to save even three months
of money I would not save that old
about say for a rainy day you
need a 90-day Reserve I wouldn't do any
of that if I was starting over today
I would go out and earn money I would
take all the money invest in something
that paid me a little drip and I'd go
out and earn some more money throw it in
another deal pays me a drip I'm not
talking about stocks I want to convert
paper to an asset that's worth more than
paper how's the cash flow and and so
most of these companies I mean we we're
going to look at a third of the
companies on the entire Stock Exchange
or zombie companies that will never
produce income ever and to work billions
of dollars they're garbage and they're
going to go into the dumper and a lot of
people are going to lose a lot of money
gambling on this so that's what
I would tell you man money's important
number two don't lose it once you get it
use it you'll lose it if you don't use
it saving money is is a is a crazy
stupid game you'll never get wealthy
doing that and the third thing is
surround yourself with great people that
are actually moving towards these same
things that are interested in money and
wealth nothing's really happened by the
way in these recessions nothing really
changed it's just an illusion that
somehow oh my God there's no money now
now the money's still there nothing's
really changed except everybody's
mindset everybody still has to eat they
still have to wear clothes they still
have to travel they still want to have
sex and procreate and have fun and go to
the movies and everybody wants to do the
same stuff you still got eight billion
people on the planet growing every day
the the thing is there's fewer people
going for it this is what I always say
man there's there's a an abundance
amount of money on planet Earth and a
shortage of people going after it and
this is the perfect time this is it go
all out bro this is it because what
happens if you 10x your efforts for for
just short periods of time maybe six or
eight or nine months and start building
out a new network of people what happens
is
people are going to back out
and you're going to look up you'll be
like there's only three or four of us on
the field
like there's only going to be a handful
of people playing the game everybody
else is just just oh I'm grateful you
know we're we're better off than the
pakistanians and the Palestinians in the
in the Cubans and the it's all you're
always comparing yourself to some third
world country that's not developed this
is what people do all the time by the
way okay uh there's some Village in
Africa where you know they don't have
running water I hear this story all the
time these people you ever been to
Africa we have food you know you don't
even know what you're talking about
you're comparing you could always find
somebody worse off to compare yourself
to when what you should be doing instead
looking up is setting an example for all
the people that are below you or side of
you that are suffering and say no man we
should be expanding and have prosperity
in all times especially in touchdowns
how can I own real estate control real
estate use the cash I have in the bank
to buy a piece of real estate and have
enough tenants pay me a check every
month I didn't do it the way my uncle
did it my uncle did it house at a time I
did it 100 units at a time my first deal
was 38 units my second deal was 48 units
my third deal was 90 units now we don't
even look at deals outside we we we that
size we look at deals 400 units 500
units now why am I telling you this and
what should you take away from this
okay my first real estate deal was one
house I bought one house
I rented it and as soon as they moved
out I had problems I had to sell the
house just like my mom had to sell the
house so the first thing I want you to
know is this not all real estate makes
you money this piece of real estate
right here this guy paid 19 million
maybe 20 million bucks to build this
house he's going to sell it for 16
million dollars okay I come here I abuse
the damn place for two or three weeks
paid a guy 150 or 300 grand for two
weeks or three weeks that we stay here
and I walk away okay he gets income from
one person or eight people a year eight
people nine people maybe 10 people a
year maybe 12 people maybe he rents it
every week
but he won't do that every year because
if it doesn't snow he won't run it
don't buy single-family homes when
somebody's not in it you got to make the
paycheck you got to pay the check okay
when I rent when I buy a hundred units
or 40 units or 30 units okay my first
deal was 38 units I never had less than
34 of those 38 units rented never did I
have less than 34 out of the 38 units
rented which was enough money to pay the
pay the the the note at the bank to pay
for the roof to be fixed to pay the
paint the tenants termites the toilets
the classified ads the problems
something my mama told me one day she's
like you don't want to get in real
estate people going to be calling you at
midnight I'm like I wish somebody would
call me I've been busting my ass my
whole damn life so somebody would call
me God damn if somebody would call me
that means they're paying me or they
want to pay me
so what you gonna do
see your parents have half of everything
right
if they're millionaires they got half of
the equation right they got just enough
money now to say hey I made a bunch of
money I took care of my kids I got them
a college degree we got a nice house and
if I get a divorce it's going to cost me
half that's all the millionaires
nobody tells you that though nobody
tells you that look if you want to make
if you want real Freedom that's what my
dad wanted to provide my mom real
freedom and he never got there because
the week after my dad died my mom had to
sell that house that is not freedom
there was no debt on the house
except for the death the government puts
on every piece of property in America
property taxes okay and if you can't pay
the property taxes if you can't pay for
the Landscaping if you can't pay to have
the lawn mowed the snow to be picked up
and moved okay the pain to be fixed the
cedar the cedar Shake that's going to
fall off this place the roof that's
going to get damaged over some period of
time
if you can't fix all that it's coming
out of your pocket you're going to be
worried when you go to sleep at night
that's why I buy apartments and Office
Buildings because they provide income
from multiple tenants at one piece of
property it could be a hundred units 200
units 500 units the bigger the bigger
the more units the more protection you
get okay listen to what I'm telling you
that's one unit big nice big ass badass
house right beautiful
okay I'm gonna give them 200 Grand 300
Grand
I'm gonna walk away from this place
okay that one section of the roof over
there could cost him 300 Grand one year
and it will by the way that roof will
not last forever it's got a 25-year life
he's got Plumbing issues here he's got
electrical Heating in the floors okay
you know the bridge is going to be a
problem we got water fountains swimming
pools that swimming pool's been at 106
degrees since I got here I'm like Crank
that bad boy all the way up who do you
think is paying the utility bill here
not me
so look not all real estate makes you
money the real estate that makes you
money is the real estate that produces
income every month positive cash flow
cash flow is the Holy Grail
the Holy Grail of all Finance is cash
flow look this these five days it's 90
minutes a day you guys carve out 90
minutes for me every day for five days
completely free cost you nothing
and I promise you I will put you on
track to become a millionaire yeah man
you know so it's not difficult you got
you I can't do the willingness thing you
guys got to sign up for it I can't do
and I know some of some of your audience
are like ah what's the strings attached
what's it uh the strings that I want to
help that's the string okay if you've
ever asked for help beg for help prayed
for Help Wanted help wanted somebody to
take time to help you this is a gift
yeah and it's my gift to you and those
that receive the gift it gives me a gift
back to me to fulfill my purpose so I
truly want to help people uh this is not
about inspiration or motivation it's not
about you getting all excited beating
your chat is real tactical dude it's a
strategy it's a specific strategy yeah
and I'd like I've never needed
motivation I don't need anybody to
motivate me I don't need to jump up and
down to get excited I don't I don't need
to do a cold plunge to want to conquer
the world or walk on fire dude I need a
strategy just show me the math yeah and
and show me that and then I'll take it
from there and I'm gonna figure it out
just like you did this is a cycle of a
business I'm going to take one little
idea and I'm gonna turn it into this 80
000 a year to go to Stanford Harvard MIT
or Yale and never learn this process
it's a true story I'm gonna write the
millionaire booklet watch what I do I'm
driving home from uh downtown Miami it
was a charity event and I gave some
money to help this charity that night
and I'm driving home and Elena's like
I'm so proud of you grant you did such a
good thing tonight I get home and I'm
like I'm gonna write a book tonight how
to become a millionaire most of you
would sit down and start writing the
book what I did next was write an offer
I'm like okay this book is going to be
uh 1995 I'm going to sell it for 9.95
it's going to be a pre-order I'm
literally calling Sherry at midnight
give me a landing site right now we're
going to call it the millionaire book
and share he's like you can't write a
book you're under contract with penguin
random right now and they get your next
book I said did we agree to a book or a
booklet she's like a book book I said
good don't call it the millionaire book
call it the millionaire booklet okay if
that don't work we'll call it the
millionaire pamphlet okay let them sue
me later in the mind the minds says oh
I'm gonna write a book and you want to
think you need to finish a product I
don't think I need to finish a product I
need to start selling books okay now I
need to Market this book well Grant the
book's not finished right now okay ain't
nobody coming to your house at 12 30 at
night to get the book I started
advertising like I got a book so you
guys won't do that
you're like but I don't have a book I
got a book I got time nobody expects to
get the book in an instant I had a
landing page up see this landing page we
added the video the next day so idea
offer Market notice I haven't written
anything now I'm going to sell it I'm
gonna close the fifth step will be to
deliver a service so what am I going to
do here right here you gotta write your
book okay I have this idea at 11 o'clock
at night at 11 20 I think we got our
first order 20 minutes after it and then
I go online and say hey guys if you
could help me translate my new book into
Arabic Hebrew can you please do this for
me and I'll give you credit for the
translation 38 languages in 30 days and
I paid a whopping zero more importantly
I got the word out on this new book now
I got to write the book by one o'clock
in the morning 1am the book was finished
now you're like man how do you write a
book so fast because I was selling books
fast honesty integrity and ethics they
have power I commit to People by accept
thing their money
the moment people start giving me money
I'm like oh I gotta deliver now if
you're a good person you should have
good things coming your way if you don't
have good things coming your way and
you're a good person that's because
something in your business cycle is
broken intention is senior to mechanics
um and I was like that that was a game
changer for me I'm like man I need to
keep for me that means like
my understanding of that concept is the
intention where I want to get
not not am I a good person or not being
what what the goal or Target is needs to
be 80 percent
of my energy
so I'm going to get to 5 billion now the
next thing I'm going to do
I'm not going to take a piece of paper
out I might take a piece of paper out
figure out how many deals I need to do
but that's where it becomes problematic
because I'm like okay if my average deal
size is 50 million and I need to get to
50 billion I need a thousand deals right
like I ain't got I can't I can't even
buy one deal right now much less a
thousand and then you get stuck in this
problem this bigger problem and then
you're like there's no way and you give
up on your goal and your intention now
and then you start cutting everything
that's why if you've ever heard me say
never reduce a Target that's what I was
talking about don't reduce the target
increase the activity
to the point to where your goals in my
case my goals should be so big that it
gives me new questions to ask
and the new question would be who do I
need to meet to do a 50 billion dollar
deal right right well the buddies that I
have right now in clubhouse Jonathan
Jerry Glenn David spezak Brian been
stuck they can't help me dude correct
those people cannot help me get to 50
billion they can they can they can be
buddies sure so that's why if you look
at that list of people I gave you
earlier that I'm studying oh yeah
they've all done 50 billion and more
right
so that's what I need to start real say
what did these cats do who who do they
know what do they now now I'll just tell
you another thing that that's crazy
because I just found this out I was I
was talking to some Wall Street guys and
I'm like dude I I hate these Wall Street
people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at me says bro it's because
you're talking to the wrong people he
didn't say bro by the way but he says
it's because Grant he's like Grant
you're not talking to the top of the
food chain
the top of the food chain
is exactly like you that's interesting
they would never judge you they would
never criticize you they would only
admire you they would want to pick up
the bill with you they would think they
were with a brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to a lot
of you've been asking me about my my
workout regimen uh some of you may or
may not know but
two years ago I couldn't do a push-up
I wasn't in terrible shape but man my
body was starting to hurt
you know I'm 63 years old so
there's no way you can't you can hold on
to it without doing the work and when I
was a kid
I was for whatever reason my metabolism
uh genetics whatever I I was never uh I
mean I was always I could just pick it
up quick
it was physically fairly strong but you
know short sharp muscles and they would
respond really quickly
and then
I started believing I could get away
with that
uh and then you start hitting 40 45 and
50. it's just no way so what I what I
did today you just saw my morning
basically my my routine I changed it up
a little bit I'm in my recovery room
right now this is a magnet uh I'll I'll
post some of the things that it does and
uh some of the benefits of it but
basically what you saw me do is finish
my workout I spent eight minutes on this
magnet
it's basically electronic magnet that
separates the cells in the body and gets
everything where it's supposed to be
it's like oxygenating all my cells then
I'll go to the egg over here sauna
and by the way I any of you that want
any of these products let me know I
represent all of them
that is a hyper Pro it is a 30 minute
30 minute uh sauna it Heats to 194
degrees
Corona cannot live it runs in real
Corona cannot live it 140.
um and that sauna to what a place to
relax man amazing
so I'll spend 30 minutes in that
[Music]
I'll spend 30 minutes in the sauna and
then I'll do 20 minutes into infrared
bed just a Mack Daddy right here this
bed right here is twenty eight thousand
dollars instead here's I know if you can
even get one
that's a hundred and uh it's the best in
the world 80 000 likes invisible
lighting like it is fantastic for
immunity runs off of a pad over here so
I can pull up everything from
uh inflammation joint pain pain recovery
anti-aging sleep immunity energy soft
tissue recovery so these are three
things I do every day you're very
Scrappy and so it's like do you ever
worry like calling out the black rocks
and these guys I mean you're basically
you know
well it's not a good thing to do if
you're going to stay small
but if you have what they want they'll
they'll forgive you
so what we're doing is we're very
strategic about collecting
the kind of assets that they are forced
to eat okay they they don't they know no
matter how big and powerful you get you
still have Achilles seals right your
your your your your business plan
becomes your
business plan
you know it becomes the thing that like
if I know your business plan then
I can participate in your business plan
so I can become a necessary evil to the
black rock or you know maybe they could
buy you someday maybe or maybe
maybe yeah maybe we do the flippy dippy
and I make my big move bro look you
don't think that these big giants can't
fall they have fallen like all you got
to do is go back hundreds of years man
stay broke stay broke y'all got to stay
broke man cash is garbage you don't need
money you don't need cash cash is trash
your mommy and daddy didn't know this
cash is garbage it is trash take it out
use it it is worthless until it is put
to work
okay listen to me money is worthless
until it is put to work
money is useless until it is used
it's a piece of paper
okay it's got God on it look how they
treat this let's put God on there man
okay we'll put it we'll put Ben Franklin
it wasn't God's idea to have his his
name on a piece of paper everybody agree
with that this is that's a pitch
come on man put Ben Franklin on this
right he's a president
okay like he ain't he ain't my president
he did
and then we act like a sacred and I got
to keep it and protect it and now it's
mine this is what this is what uh
Brandon was doing this morning we're
talking about currency if you look at
the word it comes from current current
flows it has to be in circulation
right it's it's it's plentiful it's a
piece of paper it's only valuable when I
take it out of my pocket get it out of
the system and put it to work
if I give it to the bank if I call up
Wells Fargo today and say Here's a
hundred dollars what are they going to
do with it
they're going to convert it it instantly
converted into digits and then they will
send it out nine times
almost 10x don't try to done trying to
impress anybody
but I do want to inspire people I want
to inspire you so it's been my mission
my mission has been like if I make it
one day I'm going to show you guys
behind the scenes you get to see my wife
my kids how we conduct ourselves when we
go on trips when I'm on business when
I'm at home I want to show people what
it's like to make it okay I'm not
showing you all the cars and stuff and
the planes and to to like say look at me
look at me look at me I'm saying hey man
nobody
this is my strategic
literally my my mission
is to show you everyday people whether
you live in in uh in Africa
or America Venezuela
or you live in Venice Beach California
okay look there's broke people in both
those places
there's hopeful people in both those
places men women kids I don't care your
age your sex your sexual preferences
you're doing drugs not doing drugs you
believe in them or not you're a
republican a Democrat you're a con a
capitalist or a communist
my mission is not political a mission is
to like help people see that
what is possible most people just simply
have the wrong target
most small businesses in America Break
Even or lose money because they have
their own Target they're just like I
just want to make 70 grand out of my
business I want to own my business I
want to be the boss the boss of what
you know and so so first thing we do is
fix the target what is the target this
reset is going to be create massive
opportunities this is where wealth is
created in very short periods of time
anybody can get this well because the
big money is going to sideline it has to
sideline because it's public
a little more complicated but they're
public so they have to be careful okay
and you don't you need to take risks
right now the first thing you have to do
when you want to do anything you have to
make a decision a lot of people brush
over this and so oh I got to make a
decision yeah no but you have to make a
decision
that you're going you're not going to be
the same in any event like the mo this
moment that you're having right now on
the internet watching us in this
interview you cannot re-produce this
moment you can wish it want it walk on
fire to get it you cannot reproduce it
can't happen no matter how many
decisions you make you cannot reproduce
this one moment
the future however can be created out of
decisions like what decisions am I going
to make
to go from here to there if I don't make
that decision I don't go there
everything everything follows a decision
whether you know it or not billions of
people not Millions not hundreds of
millions billions of people are going to
get smaller as a result of This Global
reset
these are resets these are these are
redistributions of wealth whether you
believe it or not if you go back the
last couple hundred years they've been
doing this over and over again you know
there's this old thing about if you took
all the money on the planet
equally distributed to everyone it would
somehow in a very short period of Time
end up in the same hands why because
those people have specific strategies
one they're making decisions to create
wealth for themselves two massive wealth
there's not little bits of well they
want massive amounts of wealth okay two
they they
um they know how to Market themselves
no I'm not talking about social media
marketing I'm talking about how do I
just Market myself with you or with you
right now how do I Market My Brand Apple
knows how to do it Coca-Cola General
Electric the the companies that are hot
Netflix knows how to do it you have to
learn how to do that in order to get
money to follow attention so the first
pillar is the decision to get bigger you
and your family have to make this
like you and your wife did yeah my wife
and I okay my kids my kids are on board
I got a 11 year old and 13 year old I'm
like look our decision is to get bigger
and that requires some sacrifices
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules from Robert Kiyosaki
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
I'll see you there the reason I go work
for McDonald's you know whether it's
seven bucks an hour or 15. I don't
really care they have the best Business
Systems in the world so right inside
little McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to learn about
business except for the management side